COLT MCANLIS: Hello, everyone,
[CHEERING]
Round of applause,
who's hung over?
[CHEERING]
Round of applause, who
needs more caffeine?
[CHEERING]
Round of applause, who's
ready for some barbecue?
[CHEERING]
There you go.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Colt McAnlis and I
am your final speaker for today,
thank god.
Sorry.
No.
AUDIENCE: We have
one more session.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, that is true.
That is true.
Yes, sorry.
And today what we're
going to be talking about
is something near and
dear to my heart--
continuous integration
for Android performance.
Asleep yet, anybody?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Nobody?
[CHEERING]
We'll get there.
Again, that's why I
asked the hung over
and the caffeinated part first.
By the way, there's
only some days
you get to wake up and make
sure that your shirt matches
your slides.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a design
decision I made today.
Here's the rub with being
an Android developer.
We're also Android users, right?
Which means we implicitly know
what it feels like for an app
to not be performant.
We know when we grab our
phone, and we start scrolling,
and it's just hitchy,
that that's not cool.
We know exactly what
it feels like to not
be able to get your
data fast enough
or see that little
stupid spinner every time
you open the app.
We understand that anger, right?
Admit it.
Round of applause,
if you've uninstalled
an app because it
was not performing up
to your expectations?
[APPLAUSE]
And guess what?
You need to remember
that feeling.
Of the billions of users on
mobile today, they all do that.
That is actually why we
like to say the perfmatters.
For the individuals who
then go to uninstall
their application
because of performance,
we found a correlation
of 73%-- they're
more likely to go give negative
feedback in the store because
of it.
And, in fact, they
will further go on
to tell their friends how
crappy their experience was
with your application just
because of performance.
The correlation is higher
for negativity on performance
than anything else.
From that standpoint,
performance
is actually a
business feature more
than it is a bunch
of bald guys yelling
about enums on the internet.
[LAUGHTER]
I see some of y'all in here.
I'll get to you in a minute.
That's why we like to say
that performance is hard.
I'm sorry.
I just realized something.
I'm given a California
keynote in Texas.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Now let's try this again.
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to start
this at top here.
I came here to do
two things today.
Number one's to kick ass and
number two's to give a keynote.
And my keynotes almost over.
[APPLAUSE]
Now listen here.
We got two things on
the agenda besides that.
Keynote performance, barbecue.
Listen, performance
is hard, y'all.
That slide translated
pretty well, in my opinion.
Performance is a hard.
Look at all this crap
you got to do, right?
First off, there is just a
jazillion devices out there
you've got to worry about.
I mean, people devices
attached to their cattle,
attached to their watches now.
I even saw, in [INAUDIBLE],
someone had a smart boot.
I don't know what it
does, but it's out there.
And you've got to worry
about performance on it.
And then the problem
is, if he does
have a problem
with his smart boot
when he's out the
fields hunting quail,
you can't repo the
performance problem.
Little do you know
that there was
a quail attached
to his boot when
he experienced that hitchiness.
But that don't mean he
ain't going to give you
a bad review for it.
So as a developer,
it's hard for you
to find these
performance bugs, right?
Can I get a hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, that's pretty.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
We're going to milk that one.
In addition to that,
when you do get the bug
and can finally actually
repo the damn thing,
you got to go to do it manually.
You got to hit the
button, and run the tool,
and get the information,
and figure it out, and then
hand it back to
someone else, who
tells you're stupid because
there wasn't a quail
in the testing environment.
I keep a well stocked
cupboard of quail, by the way.
It's a delicious
animal, if you ain't
been quail hunting this season.
The issue with that
though is that even
though you do this manual
profile, the tools are hard.
I mean, listen, they're more
complex than a snub nosed bull
inside of a cotton field.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, come on now.
So even when you can do
the manual profiling,
you've got to go through
all this bullshit
to try to get through it.
And the reason that the
tools are so complex
is that the daggone
system's complex, right?
I mean, we're talking about
stacking a bull on top
of a hayfield inside of a barn.
You can't just do that.
You can't just walk in
one day and be like,
I'm going to stack some bulls.
No.
You've got to plan it, and
you got to get some diagrams,
and you got to get Chet
there, and Chet's got
to talk about it,
and then he tells you
that you can't check
in your damn code
because it ain't
compliant to readability.
And I'll be like, I just want
to stack a damn bull today, OK?
But you can't do it
because it's too complex.
And that's all right.
I can forgive that.
But performance is
difficult because of it.
And, of course,
the final problem
is actually going in and
making the damn changes
to fix the performance
issues that you realize
the smart boot was having
with that stupid quail out
in the field.
Stupid quails.
Now don't get me wrong,
we're here in Texas
and we enjoy a little
manual labor, am I right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
COLT MCANLIS: Can
I get a hell, yeah?
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Wait.
First off, who here is
actually from Texas?
[CHEERING]
All right.
Who's here from Oklahoma?
[LAUGHTER]
Y'all go back.
Arkansas?
Oh.
Bless your heart, honey.
Bless your heart.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oklahoma.
All right.
So this is the reason that
performance is daggone hard.
It's too difficult to
build our applications
in a performant manner
because of these things.
And I've got to
tell you what, this
is the whole reason we started
the Android Performance
Patterns product.
AUDIENCE: Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS:
Joanna, this is where
you're supposed to clap
and get them all started.
No, no.
Just do it now, please.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Good help's hard to find.
This is the reason we
started this whole initiative
because it's too damn hard
to get the performance
of your applications right.
And we started this
almost a year ago now.
And we started putting the
videos online in January.
So let's see what our
little hodung group has
done in the process here.
[WEAK CLAPPING]
Nope.
That was wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
I gave you a sheet with
a time stamp on when
you're supposed to do it.
Can you just look at
the sheet, please?
Bless her heart.
She tries so hard.
So listen, actually
doing the work,
we can't help you with that?
You've got to go out there.
You've got to get your
hands dirty, right?
I mean, if you're going
to be bailing hay,
you've got to bail hay.
You can't get a machine
to bale the hay for you
because that ain't Southern.
[LAUGHING]
I can't help you with that.
That's on you.
But the complexity of the
system, now that's something
I can help with.
Again, trying to
get a bull stacked
on top of a hen inside
of a barn-- it just
doesn't work that way.
That's why this bald
man on the internet
has been rambling so much.
The systems are so complex
and it's so difficult.
You what it's like?
It's like you getting
a burger and then
asking the waitress
what color the bull was,
so you could understand the
temperature of the meat.
It don't work that way.
You need somebody to sit there
and tell you how it's actually
going to work.
And that's what these
videos have been doing.
So from our perspective,
we've got you covered there.
The complexity of the
system is all in the videos.
We've been trying to
explain it to y'all people,
especially y'all from Oklahoma.
We know you've
got some problems.
It's OK.
We're going to take little
time and explain it to you
the right way.
For now though, you've
got the complex tools.
So you can understand what's
going on underneath the hood,
but you don't know how
the daggone tools work
because it's a tennis sneaker--
my graphics guy gave me that.
I actually don't
what that would do.
Is that the smart boot, Asher?
Where's Asher?
Asher, is that the smart boot?
Did we copyright that logo?
No?
Or is it a trademark?
I forget.
Someone said, it's
a trademark, no?
I'm Southern.
So the complex tools.
So what do we do with that?
Well, the good news is,
we've got a whole, great team
dedicated to
actually letting you
know how to use these tools.
And they're on
developers.android.com.
We've gone through all of the
performance available tools
and tried to walk you
through how to actually use
them to solve your problems.
So if you combine the videos
that tell you what's going
on under the hood and you
take a look at the tooling
documentation, y'all
should be able to do this.
Unless you're from
Oklahoma or Louisiana.
[LAUGHING]
Sorry.
Now the manual profiling part.
Let's take a look at that here.
Now that's still a challenge.
I'm going to admit,
that's something
that we ain't got
around to fixing yet.
I mean, it's only been
53 weeks at this point.
But we have been making
some good changes.
This is Systrace 2.
Can I get a hell,
yeah for Systrace?
[APPLAUSE]
Now in the Systrace tool, we
understand it's really hard.
You've got to go
in there, you've
got to click the
buttons, you've got
to understand what them little
fandung boxes are doing there.
But we added something
in there for you,
if you don't know about.
See them little tags
up there at the top?
Those are alerts.
As you do a capture, we're
going to analyze your frame
information and tell you what's
going wrong in them alerts.
Now those pop up like
ticks on a mule deer.
[LAUGHING]
When you click on one of them.
Something I miss on that one?
It's just a mule deer.
They're out in the fields
out here everywhere.
You never picked
ticks off a deer?
OK.
You click on one of them.
It's going to tell, at
the bottom, the problem
that we found and how
you can go fix it.
It's kind of like
a runtime lint.
So we can help you
take your analysis
and get a little bit more
automation in finding out
where daggone problems are.
Can I get a hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
Chet, can I get a hell, yeah?
CHET: Hell, no.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm going
to make you wear the hat.
So we can't really fix that,
but we're making strides there.
So what about this
difficult to repo part?
That's actually
a little complex.
Because the issue is, on
the Google Play Console,
we can give you some really
good information, but most of it
is catered towards crashes.
Some form factor of
Android development
crashes because
some person actually
tried to use a duck bill to
communicate with his device.
And boom, there you go.
We don't really have a
lot of good information
there with respect to how to
repo performance information.
That really hurt my
mouth to say that time.
Performance.
Joanna, round of--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So we can't really do that one.
Now the different devices.
Let's get real here for
a minute because we've
been not real so far.
[LAUGHING]
So I'm sure you've
all seen a picture
like this on the internet.
It's more popular than
them Bieber pictures
that are out there now.
Bless his heart.
He needs some church.
[LAUGHING]
That's as much as I can say
about that with my PR people
watching.
Let's be honest about this.
Yes, there is a lot
of form factors.
And this is fan-goddamn-tastic.
You want to know why?
Because this allows
your constituents
to get to your application at
every-- wait, constituents?
No-- at every price point and
form factor that they need.
Individuals can make
the opportunity choice
to figure out if they want
the quail smart boot or the $3
million dollar
phone in their hand.
This is fantastic, but it
does create a problem for you,
as an individual,
on what you actually
test your performance on.
So we can't really help
you with that either.
But the good news is, when you
look at these three things that
we haven't been able to solve
as the Android Performance
Patterns initiative
over the past year,
hopefully some of y'all
see a pattern here.
Oklahoma, you see a pattern?
[LAUGHING]
They ain't left yet, so I'm
guessing they're still with me.
See those are pictures
moving on the screen.
Sorry.
We love you, Oklahoma.
When you look at
these, you realize
that there's already
a solution out there
from a technological advance
perspective that solves this.
And it is called
automated testing.
Hell, yeah for
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Raise your hand if
you use automated testing right
now?
OK.
That's all right.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Put your hands back up.
Hold on.
Why are they all
sitting over here?
That's like Gaussian
distribution
of people of people who are
actually test their damn code.
Are y'all just showing up late?
Is that what happened?
Y'all are the
preventative programmers.
And y'all just do
this shit ad hoc.
Is that what's going on here?
I just put some duct
tape on it and ship it.
We'll blame the performance
man, if it ain't right.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Hell, yeah.
We're going to go
drinking later, boy.
[LAUGHING]
So the truth is that
automated testing
solves this problem for you,
but we got a problem with that.
It's that automated
testing ain't never really
been applied to performance.
We do the testing to
be able to clicky,
clicky the button, button
and figure out where
it crashed with the duck bill.
That's a weird test.
I had to get a duck and
I had to like harness it.
It's all quacking like--
[QUACKING]
You can't tape its bill closed
because you have to feed it.
So it's--
[QUACKING]
But then you put it on
one of them little dippers
right there.
And so he gets mad
and starts pecking
at the screen, if you put a
little feed pictures on it.
And that's how we got our
testing done in the south.
I hope you all got
a better version.
Well, that's what
y'all use, right?
That's called duck testing.
Hashtag.
#ducktest.
[LAUGHING]
Automated testing
solves this, but we
haven't had a chance to apply
it to the performance realm.
I mean, in reality,
this is what you want.
You want some sort
of automated UI test
that can be run through a
bunch of different scenarios
and devices and provide for
you performance information.
Now if you had
something like that,
what could you do with it?
If you had the ability to run
continuous integration tests
and get performance
data from it,
what could that
actually give you?
Well, first off,
you can actually
watch the performance health
of your application overtime.
Hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Number two
is you can figure out
how those performance
metrics correlate to money.
Money?
(SINGING) Bam, bam, bam, money.
No?
ZZ Top, anybody?
Am I too old for that?
I see some beards longer
than mine in here,
I can't be that old.
Although, I do have the least
hair, except for that guy.
We're getting a beer later, too.
You can actually track how your
performance actually adheres
to your monetization metrics
and y'all love money, right?
Round of applause for money.
[APPLAUSE]
Round of applause for barbecue.
Aaron, I think you may have
a nice barbecue, money, trade
commission going on here.
The nice thing you
can also see is
how your memory on
your device fluctuates
based upon the duck
testing UI changes.
So you can actually see
that clicking a button
actually has these
ramifications of performance
across your environment.
And finally, you could actually
be able, when someone actually
submits a change list,
to be able to tell them
that they're stupid
because it actually
caused performance problems.
You could track that down right
to the exact CL in your GitHub.
Hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: But
again, the problem is,
we don't have this built,
which is why I am tickled pink,
ladies and gentlemen,
to announce today,
y'all going to build it.
[LAUGHING]
We got one of the
fanciest code labs
our team could come up with.
At 12:15, y'all are going to
build continuous integration
environment for performance
for your applications.
Hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: She's
trying too hard now.
It's OK.
She did spend a little
time in Oklahoma,
although she is from Texas.
A Googler was stabbed
to death today
for insinuating that someone
from Texas was from Oklahoma.
May he rest in peace.
But the truth is,
we're not done there.
Not only are y'all going to
be able to go to this code lab
and build the environment to
test your apps in a performant
manner, so you can make more
money on the back end and tell
them people checking in
code they're messing with
your performance-- but
we can't stop there
because there's still a
fantastic amount of different
Android devices out there that
you need to run this code on.
And we know that you
can't get all them
devices in your pocket, in your
environment that your testing
on, on top of your desk.
Which is why we got a
second code lab today
about how to use
Google Cloud Test,
so you can get your
performance running
application in an automated
environment on the cloud.
Can I get a hell, yeah?
AUDIENCE: (TOGETHER) Hell, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hell, no.
COLT MCANLIS: Uh oh.
Are you from Oklahoma?
[LAUGHING]
Hell no.
AUDIENCE: Worse.
Canada.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh.
Oh.
[LAUGHING]
We will pray for you.
So this is going to bring
me to my second topic today.
We covered performance.
I want to talk about
something else real quick.
I want to talk about barbecue.
That's what we're
here for, right?
I've got to tell you, as hard
as performance is, barbecue
is damn near impossible.
Now for those of us
who have been raised
on southern tradition, you
know that barbecue is not just
a cooking process,
it's about community.
It's about family.
It's about your cousin, who you
know ain't right in the head,
but you let them in your
house on Sunday anyway.
AUDIENCE: Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
what barbecue's about.
It's about coming together.
And I tell you what,
over the past year, what
we've been doing is trying to
build one hell of a community.
And I've got to thank everyone
of you in the room here today
because y'all have
been a part of that.
Y'all have been
watching the videos.
You been on the
Google+ community.
You've been using the
perfmatters hashtag.
And I cannot tell you how
humbled I am that you're all
part of our barbecue.
Thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]
But let's talk about
something real quick.
[LAUGHING]
Even though y'all
are wrong-- Yes.
If you've got the
shirt, stand up.
Stand up.
Stand up, if you've
got the shirt.
One, two, three.
Round of applause for
these wrong people.
[APPLAUSE]
Bless their hearts.
They came today despite--
these are the cousins you
invite to the barbecue.
Right there.
They just stood up.
Well done.
I've got to tell you what, this
is what I love more than ever.
Y'all can argue with me until
I'm pickled in the face,
it don't matter.
I will sit there and argue
with you happy, happy, happy
as a cat on a hot tin
roof because this means
you're part of our barbecue.
It means you're passionate
enough about performance.
And your code base--
you're willing to argue
with a bald man on the internet.
And I know how hard that is.
Thank you for being
part of all this.
Thank you for being and loving
performance and everything
we do.
So I've got to
tell you, from all
of the team that work on
this-- it ain't just me.
It ain't just one, bald
man running around.
We've got a whole team
back at Google HQ.
I want you all to give
them a round of applause
because not all of
them are here today.
[APPLAUSE]
This team works so hard in
getting these videos done,
the documents done,
everything together.
They're the ones to thank.
I'm just the great looking
man on the internet
who gets to talk about it.
AUDIENCE: Hell, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Hell, yeah.
Was that guy bald who said that?
So with that, I'm going to let
y'all get to the conference
today.
We've got a fantastic
goddamn conference.
When y'all go out there, I want
you to remember three things.
Number one?
AUDIENCE: Keep calm.
COLT MCANLIS: Number two?
AUDIENCE: Profile your code.
COLT MCANLIS: Number three?
AUDIENCE: Always
remember, #perfmatters.
COLT MCANLIS: Hey,
get some barbecue.
Thank y'all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]